Good friends are basically family, right?
Um YES.
Because science.
Hello folks, Laci Green here for DNews.
Friends are great.
You share so much with them: interests, crushes,
perhaps even your latest bowel movement!
But now scientists are finding that besties
even share GENES!
Scientists at Yale and UC San Diego have found
that we share a huge amount of genetic material
with our friends - that huge amount being
1%.
OK, sounds kinda small, but to geneticists,
it’s off the charts!
For some perspective, you also share 1% of
your genetic code with your fourth cousins,
which is when you share a great-great-great-grandparent.
It’s kind of crazy, it’s like we seek
out close friends who resemble our family.
Just don’t make out with friends, cuz that’s
basically incest now.
To figure this crazy factoid out, scientists
examined around 2000 people in a racially
and ethnically homogenous area - which is
usually not good for scientific studies, but
in this case IS good because this rules out
a tendency to befriend people who share our
race.
Then they looked at around 1300 pairs of friends
and examined 1.5 million markers of gene variation.
The highest genetic correlate we share with
our friends is a thing pertaining to your
sense of smell (which explains why my friends
love my impeccable taste in fragrances).
The lead researchers say that it could be
the sense of smell that brings people together
into the same environment.
On the opposite end of things, friends are
more dissimilar than strangers on genetic
protection from diseases.
Which is amazing because it’s a sort of
person-to-person protection against the spread
of disease.
What the researchers find the MOST interesting
though, is the fact that those genes you share
with your friends are evolving more quickly
than other genes.
Could our social environment speed up evolution?
I dunnoooo….that’s kind of what it looks
like.
We’ll need more studies to test that theory,
though it could be one possible explanation
for WHY and HOW we manage to share more genes
with our friends.
Right now the scientists say they’re not
quite sure why this happens.
BUT, say we have a shared skill in our genes
-- that brings us together, in which case
it could be evolutionarily advantageous to
have each other to develop that skill, thus
the faster evolution of the genes.
I guess we’ll just have to wait and see
what else they find - and we’ll keep you
updated here on DNews.
Thanks for joining me, what do you have MOST
in common with your friends?
Tell me bout it down below and we’ll catcha
next time!